hi there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey
expectations vs. reality martial arts
movies this comes from a channel called
Marshall Club and see one of our top of
our chairs at patreon is whatever a
video you're requested was doing put up
on YouTube so today comes from our great
friend David Gandy who is part of this
type of warrior didn't have one for last
month but now he has this one for a
Parral I really am a big fan of fight
scenes a lot of times if you're ever at
like a party with me and we're all
showing each other videos I have the
habit of like let me show you this fight
scene let me show you this fight scene
actually very recently I was taking my
girlfriend Olivia down a binge path of
like some of my favorite fights from
Hong Kong cinema this sounds like it's
gonna be a little more funny but let's
check it out anyway I'm a big fan of
reality and I show people just lots of
videos of real things happening so like
a reaction
maybe in the girl
that's very Jackie Chan yeah super-good
[Music]
oh snap
it was like uh Peking Opera style I love
it dude with like the speed of like
violence
it's very Donnie Yen ish
if I date army apply so funny oh this is
straight out of it man nice oh oh yes
yes I love it it's Tsui Hark
yes oh yeah
more people should watch that movie so
bad
[Music]
[Music]
every Monday subscribe notification Bell
clicking that bad boy every Monday right
now oh I was awesome that was awesome
it was like straight-up tributes to a
lot of my favorite kind of fight scenes
there and looking at it it says right
there it's an faking we offer let's root
Jackie Chan and you and Lupita from and
in LA and Donny yeah yeah yeah
especially the final fight for the it
man at the end right there this is
wonderful it was like nothing short of
amazing to me guys are like super great
at fighting but they also clearly know
there are different kinds of
choreography and stuff like that and
their martial arts history was email and
they also have a great sense of comedy
as well I did Taekwondo for 10 years and
one of the weaker things that I would
always encounter is like you martial
arts is something that people take very
seriously obviously to get this skill
you have to take it very serious but you
often find that when you're not in the
dojo and sometimes at the dojo
like people are like very goofy it's
kind of because you know martial arts
can be like kind of a silly thing when
you think about it there's a slapstick
ich miss yeah totally so it's really
cool to see that these guys who are
clearly expertly trained martial artists
I would love to see these guys make it
actual film I would love to see you
guest star in one of their
you know that would be cool so you can
fight I would train for one month again
yes you'll be able to do the kicks and
everything like that and then give up on
it right after you should have one fight
seen many years ago on this channel find
it raid 300 and the concept - of
expectations vs. reality I don't know if
women go through that in terms of like
getting into fights imagination I go
through that on the daily yeah like
every single time I you know see any
kind of conflict - whether it's on the
street or even at the gym my imagination
makes me think I'm gonna be a badass to
go in there and help solve this call
even beats up that there's something
with a woman made her ass I would do so
that's what made it so funny is it
because it's like I think most guys
would even if you are scared of this
situation I think a lot of guys even
with I can't speak for most guys I feel
like even if in a situation like that
even if I thought I'm gonna get my ass
kicked like well it's it's worth it if
this girls getting harassed I might as
well give it a shot anyway if it means
doing the right thing you know what if
you win she has to fall in love with you
that's the rules
right well that's part of the funny
behind it is when like you're into a
girl or something and you imagine that
oh the way for her to to truly see you
see how much you care how cool you are
you want to rescue her I got the most
physical sense my saving her life way
make you feel so safe in my presence
it's been such like a dude thought at
least for me I think a lot of guys go
through they just don't admit to it I
flashed to that moment and dumb and
dumber when Jim Carrey saved Mary at the
restaurant he's like standing up for her
honor because he's like she was
disrespected I'm gonna be a total badass
in front of her and that's like the joke
of this whole thing is the expectation
versus reality of like our mind makes us
think oh man
if I was in that situation with the
reality even even for like actual
martial artists and that's a very
different environment as opposed to
being an adult or something like that as
opposed to competing in the street fight
it's like you can freeze up I remembered
growing up and I would be sparring every
every day but then for some reason if
there was like a fight at school or
something or I was at a party your
instinct was I would freeze up
I wouldn't like participate or I
wouldn't want to get involved as opposed
to you know like technically I have a
skill set where I could get involved but
yet I wouldn't I think it's like doing
martial arts and even practicing
frequently in a dojo has an expectations
vs. reality sort of quality about it cuz
that you can learn to be proficient you
can spar you can get great at doing
everything that once you're in reality
and there are now stakes and you can
actually get hurt and no one's gonna do
anything about it yeah you know it all
changes yeah for sure and also to I like
that it's also about the numbers cuz in
martial arts movies you'll see like one
do too frequently takes on five people
whereas like in that scenario there's
three guys even if you can make a
difference it's probably not gonna work
in your favor ultimately I know I
thought it was gonna be a little more
violent yeah with the black belt one
we're all just piling on him yeah
because I remember when I was young
there were these two second-degree black
belts who had some type of like real
personal rivalry with each other and I
didn't know why I was too young to
understand what was going on but they
they went outside of the dojo and that
had gone into a fight and they didn't
fight like we're doing for of and
obeying rules like second-degree black
belt just turned to a full-on street
fight at that point like arm swinging
around and [ __ ] and straight-up tackling
it wasn't like oh it wasn't form and
fancy so that's what I mean it's like
literally in the dojo then they went to
the alley to have just a full-on fight
but it was cool about the final moment
in this was a it's a tribute to you know
it's funny I've seen the first three
Donnie Yen movies of that and I even saw
a third one of the theatres and I still
don't know if it's I always forget is it
Ip Man or hip man its intellectual
property yeah one of the two and I
always forget which one it is
they do a tribute to it and it's a
really cool tribute and of course it's
in a park if you're gonna do a fight
scene on a low budget it's gonna be in a
park that public race everyone does
their fight scenes
have a camera and be doing exercise
honestly when when they showed the first
fight I was thinking to myself oh that's
cool son at a park users overly out of
park yeah and then okay they're at a
party yeah yeah they just saved it for
life yeah and then the reality of it is
it wouldn't go down like that at all
even though we want to think it's cool
and everything but not to own one black
belt so troubling situation this was
great expectation reality I'm gonna
watch way more of these guys actually
David also sent over another one called
Shazam parody fight scene which I will
want to check out later on I didn't
realize there'd be so much you're like
yeah I want to see more of these guys
please please go subscribe to this
channel and go check out the actual this
has over a million views right now but
get it even more views dude they deserve
it
and David David himself has actually
been in martial arts training and he's
up in the Bay Area
he wrote this video he wrote this video
because he is constantly he's going
through all the tests and everything I
forget what belt you are at now but he's
actually under the tits under the
umbrella of the Ernie Reyes category
Reyes jr. who was famous in the 90s surf
ninjas his dad or near a his senior and
he's kicking ass and we talked a lot
about how it's really changed a lot of
his lifestyle in general so David I'm
proud of you keeping up with the martial
arts clearly your horizon is expanding
even more by looking into like these
kind of videos thanks for sending this
over dude this is a great channel to be
introduced I'm gonna check out more from
these guys and I want to fight you I
will fight David one day one day we will
fight you we together
Jeff will handle majority all things you
all Greg does he still more flexible
than all right well you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and hey I want
you to go ahead and check us on patreon
with your TV show reaction stream along
with weekly Q&A is and John does plenty
of music video coverage throughout the
week and I occasionally join it for that
as well
peace out